une fin d'année qui signe un triste
record en allemagne plus de 1100 morts
en 24 heures à cause du coffee de 19 ce
mercredi avec des chiffres de
contamination qui ne baisse quasiment
plus depuis une semaine plus de 22 mille
nouveaux cas ont été détectés en un jour
des chiffres loin de permettre de lever
les gestes barrière ces chiffres
montrent une fois de plus à quel point
ce virus est brutale les infections et
le nombre de décès montre également que
nous sommes encore très loin de la
normalité dans laquelle nous
souhaiterions vivre en tête des régions
les plus touchées
la saxe particulièrement réfractaires
aux mesures de restriction viennent
ensuite la bavière le brandebourg ou
encore berlin dans ces länder
la fermeture des commerces non
essentiels des écoles et le télétravail
en vigueur depuis déjà quinze jours
n'ont toujours pas montré leur
efficacité
la nouvelle variante du coronavirus plus
contagieuse détectés au royaume uni
pourrait être responsable de la
virulence de l'épidémie ces dernières
semaines ce mardi les autorités ont
annoncé qu'elles étaient présentes dans
le nord du pays dès le mois de novembre
submergé par la deuxième vague de
coronavirus l'allemagne a démarré
dimanche dernier sa campagne de
vaccination priorité aux seniors et
personnel soignant
soixante mille personnes ont reçu les
premières doses berlin assure qu'il
disposera de 3 à 4 millions de doses
d'ici fin janvier
en attendant l'allemagne envisage de
prolonger le confinement partiel au delà
du 10 janvier
[Applaudissements]